you know I went to the inauguration days
of my life
I am consumed with that I was thinking
about you that day I was watching you
more than I was watching your rump first
of all I don't even know how you get
past you've got three million more votes
than I got it right a my mind you won
the election the Electoral College I
can't explain that I don't under who
felt it was his rights we're gonna be
denied but the majority of the people in
the country voted for you you got the
job done great when you stand in there
watching this guy uh what the hell is
going through your head are you just I
would imagine you were on
antidepressants that day you know how
here's how I felt about it I mean
obviously I was crushed I was
disappointed and I was really surprised
because I couldn't figure out what had
happened and you hadn't even written a
losing speech when you lost that only
victory know and and every everything
was pointed in that direction so when
he's going to be inaugurated I was going
as a former first lady right that was
the reason I was there I was no longer
in the Senate I was a secretaries of
state don't usually attend so I was but
your sense of duty is my husband was
president I was first lady and this is
what we say to the country there's
continuity that is exactly how I felt
and a lot of people said to me don't put
yourself through that don't go and I
said look I ran for president because I
love this country
I wanted to serve this country I thought
I would have been a really good
president I want he would have been
spectacular well you're out period yeah
I hope our own affairs yep but I'd be
crushing NATO right now I don't think so
no no we need them but you're standing
up so so on I said to myself isn't
everybody who talked to me about it look
I hope he's gonna be a better president
than I think he will be I'm worried
about it but I'm gonna do everything I
can as I told him when I called him you
know that terrible night exactly I did I
said you know I said look you know
Donald I want you to be a good president
I will do whatever I can to help you so
you know we're in this generation or was
he ass or was so shocked he couldn't he
could barely four
and me I think Wow yeah he was shocked
right and and so when I got there you
know go ahead get out there you you put
on the best face possible and I'm you
know bill and I are sitting with George
and Laura Bush and then he started on
that speech which was so bizarre and
that's when I got really worried I
thought wait a minute
it wasn't rational it's not rational but
it's also not it's not politics it's not
what a president does a president is
supposed to try to reach out to people
who weren't for him or her you're
supposed to say okay I'm gonna be the
president of everyone those who
supported me and those who didn't
because we're gonna pull the country
together I'd hoped that I would hear a
little of that I didn't hear any of that
and then that carnage in the street and
the dark dystopian vision I was sitting
there like just wow couldn't believe in
george w bush says to me well that was
some weird [ __ ]